I'll bet how much 100 bucks how much you
got not as much as you
I'll bet beg I don't think we're going
to have a thousand dollars all right
shake hands why do you think there won't
be an election because I think the
corruption is just beginning to uh come
out and I think it's going to Avalanche
the corruption of the Biden
Administration and the money they took
versus going to be about Ukraine and
Russia then it's going to go into China
then it's going to go into without the
O.J and it's going to be like a big old
Bill Thompson election huh that would
prompt an election no because I think
that it's going to get so bad in the
streets too that I think the military is
going to step in modern day elections
I'm concerned that there's going to be a
dog and pony show and they're like hey
everybody voted and they're like hey but
we're just gonna go in the back room and
count it and tell you what the answer is
you're like dude show me the votes